[Narrator] The first 3 questions on this homework is so that you understand conditional probability.
For these 3 questions, we are going to use the relative frequencies of vowels in English,
and I'm giving you those results as a percentage of all the letters in a sample of typical English text.
You can assume that 13% of all letters in the text are the letter E,
8% are A, 7% are O, 7% are I, and 3% are U.
Obviously, this is not a very audacious sample of English text.
For question 1, assume some letter X is drawn randomly from English text
with the same distribution as we've collected here.
Give the value of the probability that X is a vowel.
Your answer should be in the range from 0-1,
so a real number where 0 means it could never occur, 1 means it always occurs.